Good afternoon.
My name is Heathrow and I'm a research operations manager on the insights lab
part of brand studio.
And we're here today for a talk by Gloria Mark.
Gloria mark is a professor in the Department of Informatics at the University of
California in Irvine and her research focuses on how the use of technology
affects our lives in real world contexts.
She received her phd in psychology from Columbia University and before working
at Uci she worked at the German National Research Center for Information
Technology and has served as a visiting researcher at Microsoft research since
2012 as well as IBM and the MIT media lab.
Today she's going to talk about her work using sensors,
experience sampling,
computer logging,
and repeated surveys to study the workplace experience specifically how
attention,
focus,
stress,
and effect are impacted by digital media use as well as how our attention focus
varies over the workday.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Gloria.
Mark.
Thank you.
So it's,
it's a real pleasure to be here at so far away from Irvine.
So I am really interested in understanding how digital media affects our lives.
And how does this clicker cups?
Okay.
So my starting point is that most people are by nature monochronic.
And what that means is most people like myself prefer to start on a task and
finish it through to completion before switching to something else.
But we live in a digital age and we are required to work in a polychronic way.
So most people have multiple devices.
You work on multiple applications,
you have multiple apps open on your laptop,
does top,
um,
some people have iPads and we're always switching our attention between devices
and applications.
And it forces us to work in a polychronic way.
And that's against what our nature is.
So in particular,
I'm very interested in the idea of multitasking and people sometimes think of
multitasking is working on two things at the same time.
And that's impossible for human beings to literally work on two things at the
same time.
You can walk and Chew Gum,
but this is an unconscious kind of a process.
But what it really refers to is switching very rapidly between different tasks,
between different contexts.
You can think of it like timesharing among computers,
right?
So when we talk about multitasking,
that's really what we're referring to,
this rapid context shifting back and forth.
Now a lot of people have tried to measure multitasking and the most typical way
that is measured as you ask people,
how much do you multitask?
Well,
this is not very fruitful because research has shown that people can be off by
about 30% in their estimates of how much time they spend on computing or just
estimating time.
In general.
People are notoriously bad at estimating time.
You could bring people in a laboratory and you can give them some kind of
artificial task and watch how fast or how well they switch.
But that's artificial and it doesn't begin to model all the kinds of things we
experience in real world work,
like career trajectories and conflicts and social pressures and deadlines and
how tired we feel and so on.
So my perspective is that if we really want to study people and understand them,
we have to go where people are.
So we have to create living laboratories and that's what I do.
And if you do this kind of approach,
we can ask questions like how fragmented is our attention with digital media?
How can we explain distraction with digital media?
How does digital media use affect mood?
Because it does.
So let me start off by talking about the introduction of digital media in the
workplace.
So I'm very often as well,
gee,
didn't people always multitask?
You know,
what is new about this?
So let's take a look.
So unfortunately nobody has,
uh,
done any study at the level of detail that we have where we use sensors and
track behavior to the second,
uh,
which I'll talk about shortly.
But what people have done is that historically they followed people around in
the workplace and they've timed them to see what their distribution of time is
with different activities.
And if you look here at these,
um,
the all the,
uh,
the,
the studies that are represented in the two right columns represents studies
that were done when um,
personal computing and email,
uh,
became widespread in use in the workplace and the studies to the left,
they were not really in widespread use the study Stevens et Al 1992.
That was sort of mixed.
And I want you to look in particular at how desk work has changed and how
scheduled beaning scheduled meetings refers to formally scheduled face to face
meetings.
And I want you to look at these two columns on the right and contrast that with
the work done by the other studies and the Hornen Lupton study in 1965 with
scheduled meetings as a bit of an anomaly.
And tell me if you notice any trends here.
You notice anything?
What,
what do you notice?
What's changed?
Hut.
Okay.
The amount of time is spent at the desk is increasing.
And what about and meetings are decreasing?
So if we put these two
trends together,
right,
we see that proportion of time spent at dusk,
we're nearly doubled with the introduction of uh,
it in the workplace and people spend a less proportion of their time and
scheduled face to face meetings.
And this suggests that work that was formally done in face to face meetings is
now being done to a larger extent at the desktop,
through email,
through desktop conferencing,
through other kinds of means.
So I'm very fortunate to be interested in this topic,
uh,
at the cusp of a revolution in the development of sensor technology,
wearable technologies,
and other kinds of sensor technologies.
And so,
you know,
I used to my students and I used to track people in the workplace.
We used to shadow people and we had these timers and every time people would
take a different action,
like pick up the phone,
we would do start time,
they'd put the phone down,
stop time,
and recorded every single action that people dead.
And it was very,
very labor intensive.
But the advantage is that we can understand the context,
right?
So as a byproduct of measuring these activities,
we've got a sense of what people's work life was like.
But when you use sensors,
you miss that context,
right?
You're only,
the sensors are just recording bits of information.
And so the grand challenges as I see it is to what extent can we automatically
capture behavior,
was sensors to gain the same level of insights,
the same level of deep knowledge we can about human behavior that we could with
human ethnographic observation.
Ethnographic observation is when people actually follow people around and
observe.
And there's a,
I have several projects that,
uh,
that I've been working on today.
I won't only talk about the health sense project,
which,
uh,
which is dealing with information workers.
I have another large star study,
the millennial project,
which tracked college students and their use of digital media.
So let me go through the measures that I use because this is going to help you
understand the data.
So we measure stress using heart rate monitors.
Uh,
we measure electrodermal activity using these devices that are called Affectiva,
Tiva Q sensors.
Uh,
actually these days we're using other wearable devices.
we measure people's mood and focus through something called experience sampling.
These are probes that people get where they record their subjective opinion
about something.
And I'm going to talk about that later.
That's in the upper right is an example of what a probe looks like.
A,
we measure face to face interaction with sense cams.
That's this lower rate picture.
It's a,
it's a small little camera,
very lightweight people where it takes continual photos about every 20,
30 seconds.
And then we can apply a phase detection software to see if there was a face
present or not in the image.
And it's very accurate.
We log people's computer and phone activity.
Uh,
we measure people's activity using actographs,
which everyone knows a fitbit as as a common actograph.
We measure sleep,
sleep rhythms,
and we give a whole lot of demographic and personality kinds of measures.
So let me start by giving you an example of what your digital media use can
reveal about you.
Now some people have done this kind of work where they mine the content,
so they analyze the content.
For example,
in social media,
they look at,
they do sentiment analysis to see what kind of words people are using.
But if we just look at temporal features,
right?
No content,
but temporal future is like the average amount of time you spend on digital
media,
the dispersion,
are you using it all at one time or using it throughout the day?
Uh,
when is the device on and an off?
How much social media are you using?
Again,
not content,
uh,
what's your rhythm of usage?
Do you have a regular pattern or is it irregular?
What time of day is it mostly used?
And we find that we can predict personality.
These are the big five personality traits if you're familiar with them.
This is a commonly used measure of personality.
We can predict these traits from temporal features alone with fairly high
accuracy.
Okay,
so let's,
uh,
start with,
um,
a question very much related to multitasking,
which is how fragmented is people?
Are People's attention in the workplace and by fragmented,
how much do they actually switch?
Context?
Okay.
So
here is a measure from logging people's computer activity activity.
This is the average duration of time that people spend on any computer screen
before switching.
And if you look at all computer usage than median length of time is 40 seconds.
That means that every 40 seconds people are switching on average rate while it's
actually the median to another screen.
That's a very short amount of time.
And if we look at averages of how often people switch within apps,
that means you open up word and then you're opening up other documents within
word or you're surfing the internet.
People switch about 112 times a day.
And switching between Apps,
which is even more of a context shift going from the Internet to a word document
to email,
that's about 261 times a day.
So,
okay.
Uh,
no this as,
sorry that that is seconds.
But this,
the switches within apps in between apps actually refer to number of instances,
sorry,
sorry about that.
That's uh,
shouldn't,
should be labeled differently.
So people's workday typically is characterized by very short durations of
attention on any computer screen and lots of switching.
There is an assumption made that the,
that when a computer screen is in the forefront and active,
we make an assumption that that's a proxy for attention.
And it's not always the case.
Now we do,
we do have decision rules.
So if a screen comes up really quick and then goes off,
we make this assumption that people's attention,
it's not long enough for people to really focus,
right,
to have any kind of meaningful focus.
So we have decision rules where we filter out screens that are just up for,
for very brief moments of time.
So for example,
sometimes people might switch,
click on a web page and then click immediately to something else.
So we disregard that because we,
you know,
we,
we can't expect that people are actually going to,
um,
focus and spend cognitive resources when that shift is so fast.
The median focused ration on any computer screen we find is seconds.
Now we wondered that maybe,
you know,
not everybody has a,
like maybe there are individual differences that can explain focus duration.
And so we hypothesize that the following things would be related to people's,
the amount of time that people would spend focused on any computer screen.
Uh,
neuroticism is a personality trait.
It's characterized by people who just can't suppress thoughts that come into
your head.
And people who are highly neurotic generally have short attention spans.
A,
we hypothesize that people who are impulsive would have a shorter attention span
on the computer.
There are two dimensions of impulsivity that we checked.
One is a sense of urgency,
right?
You,
you can't hold yourself back.
You just have to act another dimension,
lack of perseverance,
right?
That people just don't have what it takes to persevere on a task.
People who are susceptible to stress.
And we hypothesize that people who did not sleep to not have a long sleep
durations the night before would have shorter attention,
uh,
durations.
And we also hypothesize that the longer the attention duration on any computer
screen would be associated with a higher assessed productivity at the end of the
day.
And the neuroticism and impulsive urgency hypotheses were supported.
There was strong trend for this sleep and stress hypotheses to be supported and
productivity.
This hypotheses was supportive.
We also did what's called a factor analysis where we put all these variables
into a program to see if there was a latent structure in the variables.
And indeed we found a latent variable that we label lack of control,
which is comprised of people that are high in neuroticism,
who are high in this impulse of urgency,
kind of a variable and people who are susceptible to stress.
And this is predictive.
The more lack of control people have,
the shorter is there focus duration.
And I'm going to come back to this idea of lack of control later.
Now you might be asking,
well,
so what,
so what if I,
you know I switched from excel to word to email,
but what if I'm working on the same project?
Right?
Maybe it doesn't make a difference,
right?
Cause I'm right now I'm just talking,
I'm agnostic to task and I'm just talking about these switches between computer
screens.
So let's go a little bit deeper and let's look at the task level.
This is work that was done by a former student of mine,
Victor Gonzalez,
with great effort who categorized people's BS,
smaller actions into,
you know,
clustering them into different tasks and took him a great deal of time.
And here's what he found that first of all,
people work in an average of about 12 different projects.
We call these working spheres,
spheres of work.
And people spend about 10 and a half minutes in any of these working spheres
before switching to something else.
So 10 and a half minutes is not a really long period of time.
And I know,
you know,
I'm an academic and I write papers and 10 and a half minutes is not a very long
time for me to get sufficiently deep into beginning a task.
And then I'm switching.
So let's look at rhythms of attention over the day.
So I want to give you a little bit of psychology theory.
Uh,
so there's a number of researchers who've talked about this idea of attention
focus,
and it goes by different names.
It goes by the term cognitive absorption.
Others have called it cognitive engagement.
How many of you have heard of mindfulness?
Okay,
you're living in La,
you know about mindfulness,
how many of you have heard of flow?
Okay?
Flo is the idea that you're so deeply immersed with your attention that you
become completely unaware of the passage of time.
So all of these ideas are related.
And then in contrast,
people speak about boredom.
And the research shows that all of these different constructs related to
attention are associated with positive effect.
People are happy when they're deeply immersed and engaged,
and when they're bored,
generally people are not happy.
And that's what the research studies show.
So here's how you might conceptualize attention being highly engaged or not
engaged in some activity,
right?
That's a simple continuum.
And so we thought about this and we hypothesized that there would be an
orthogonal dimension that we call challenge.
And we came up with this idea because the concept of flow involves challenge
when people are in a state of flow,
right?
They're all well,
they're also challenged to some degree.
And so we came up with this conceptual framework and we put labels on these.
Let me explain them.
So people who are highly engaged and highly challenged,
we use a label of focus.
This is when people are in a state of focus and if people are really engaged in
something,
but they're not at all challenged,
we call this rote as in rote work.
An example is playing solitaire,
right?
When people play solitaire,
you're really engaged but you're not challenged.
And the other,
uh,
label board is when you're not at all challenged and you're just not engaged.
We label that board.
And the last one is being challenged in something,
but you're not engaged.
We call that frustrated is just a label.
A,
an example would be a software developer who has a bug.
They're just really,
really frustrated.
They're challenged by it and they're just can't engage themselves into trying to
work it out.
I mentioned that this is the probe that we used.
So we gave people these,
uh,
probes throughout the day on the average about 18 times a day.
People were asked that the top part is,
uh,
called Russell circumplex model of mood.
Uh,
it's,
it's a well validated measure of moods,
self reported mood.
And the bottom we asked people how engaged were you in the thing you were just
doing and how challenged where you and the thing you were just doing.
People were trained in this and they were able to answer these probes about it
within a few seconds.
Uh,
these probes came about 18 times a day.
And the irony is not lost on me that we're interrupting people 18 times a day,
but we got really great data and people submit this.
We get a timestamp and we can align the timestamps.
So we see what people's subjective moods and,
uh,
engagement and challenges in relation to the computer activities that they're
doing.
And we also look at stress and we have other metros.
So in contrast to what all this other research shows that people are happiest
when they're engaged,
we actually find that the mean level of happiness is highest when people are
doing rote work.
So when people are doing this kind of mindless work,
you're engaged,
but you're just not using your mental resources.
That's when people are the happiest.
So if we slice up this,
uh,
this idea of engagement and attention and we slice it up in terms of being
challenged and not challenged,
we find there is a difference.
People are least happiest when they're bored.
And you're saying,
why are there data aligns with frustrated?
That's because hardly anyone in our sample reported being frustrated.
So we didn't have enough data to,
to make any conclusions.
That's
this is what the average attention,
uh,
looks like over the course of the day.
Uh,
the black line is focused and there's a couple of interesting things about this
graph.
So people are at their peak focus in the morning,
about 11:00 AM so late morning and also roughly about 3:00 PM.
Uh,
and what's also interesting,
at least for me is that people don't come into the workplace ramped up and ready
to go,
but it takes some time to ease into,
uh,
into a deeper attentional state.
Okay.
Let's talk about distractions.
It's
so first one of,
um,
an,
an interesting idea about interruptions is we always think of interruptions in
terms of external notification,
right?
You,
you get an email notification or social media notification or a colleague comes
into the office or you get a phone ringing.
But there's this other phenomenon called in we call internal interruptions or
self interruptions.
The best way I can describe it is you're observing someone and they're typing in
a word doc and for no apparent reason,
they suddenly stop what they're doing and they turn and pick up the phone or
they stop and they check email or social media.
That's a self interruption.
I know I do it.
Since I've been doing this research,
I became much more aware of how much I do at now.
We type the data and we divided it up into our lease segments and we looked at
the,
um,
the proportion of external and the internal interruptions in each of those
hourly segments throughout the day,
over the course of a days.
And we found something really interesting that when external interruptions
waned,
we saw that internal interruptions kicked in and started to become high.
It's not that when an external interruptions stop that people suddenly had piece
of mind and we're able to work without interruptions.
They began to interrupt themselves.
That's what the data showed.
And this suggests to me that people are conditioned to be interrupted,
to work in very short attention spans.
And if you're not being interrupted by external sources than people will
interrupt themselves.
And that would be a sign of being conditioned.
Okay.
Now
distractions.
There is this,
um,
you know,
a lot of work has been done in interruptions and people have assumed in this
work that people are,
you know,
really absorbed in their work.
And then along comes a distraction and all of a sudden people get bored,
right?
Along comes as social media distraction and then it takes you away from this
deep engagement.
Well,
what if it's the reverse?
What if people are first in a state of boredom and that makes them susceptible
to a distraction?
And so that's the question we asked.
So first,
uh,
let me tell you a little bit about types of interruptions.
So workplace communications comprise 40% of interruptions.
Uh,
there's an email.
These are the,
these are the top,
uh,
offenders.
Uh,
email is primarily work related,
at least in the workplace as we studied.
They were face to face can be either work related or social and faced Facebook,
which was the main social media platform used in the particular company we
studied.
That's primarily social.
And to give you an idea of the extent to how much,
you know,
how often and how much people spend on these types of communications.
We see people in our sample visited Facebook about 21 times a day.
Email checked about 74 times a day.
The high person in our sample was about 465 times a day.
Uh,
but people spend relatively short durations of time.
They check Facebook but then spend about 18 seconds on it and email,
you know,
they check it off in but spend just about 32 seconds.
So they don't it.
This is the typical profile of the information worker who we studied.
And here's what we find.
When we looked at the data,
we found,
you know,
based on this experience sampling from the probes that when people were in a
state of focus,
they spent significantly longer on email compared to the other states and the
other communications types.
Uh,
when people were either bored or in a state of wrote doing rote work,
they spent significantly longer doing face to face interaction after and when
people were in a state of rote work,
it was followed significantly by longer duration of Facebook use.
And the way to interpret this data is that people first adopt particular
attentional states,
particular states of mind,
which make them susceptible to particular kinds of interaction.
Let's talk about email.
So it took me six years to find a field site that was willing to let itself be
cut off,
uh,
to have its employees be cut off by email for a workweek.
And the reason we wanted to study this was to see can we create an environment
where people would have less interruptions,
couldn't they focus longer?
Right?
And so here's what we found.
We had people in this workplace,
uh,
we measured them in their baseline condition and then we cut off their email for
a work week and we have them wear heart rate monitors,
which is,
provides a measure of heart rate variability.
It's the variability of the distance between consecutive heartbeats.
And we find that without email,
people spent significantly longer duration of focus on any computer screen.
Uh,
and then the flip side,
if you want to look at the data from,
uh,
the flip side,
you can see that they switched about half as often.
Uh,
now heart rate variability revealed that people were significantly less
stressed.
You're looking at that number and you're saying,
wait a minute,
it's higher.
What,
how can that be?
That's because,
uh,
the higher the variability of people's heart rate intervals,
they intervals between the beats,
uh,
the more relaxed people are.
And that's because the least little bit of stimulus will cause you to jump
right?
And it creates higher variability.
You're really stressed.
You're in this fight or flight kind of syndrome.
You know,
the bear is chasing you ready to run and you're a heartbeat's are more regular.
So we find longer focus and we find,
um,
people are less stressed without email.
Let's talk about workplace mood and social interactions.
So there's two ways to think,
to measure workplace mood.
So,
first of all,
we wanted to see if people's face to face interaction would produce a different
kind of mood in the workplace.
Then online,
uh,
social interactions.
And again,
as I mentioned,
Facebook was the most common,
uh,
platform used in this company.
There's two ways of looking at this at the time they occur,
right?
What makes people happier?
And so let me ask you,
how many of you think at the time they occur face to face interactions,
make people happier than Facebook?
How many of you'd think,
okay,
how many of think that Facebook doing of Facebook interaction makes people
happier?
Okay,
the answer is face to face.
Um,
we can also look at those at the end of the day because this is really important
because the mood people have at the end of the day carries over into their
personal lives.
So this is really important to look at.
How many of you think the more time spent on Facebook is associated with a
happier mood at the end of the day?
Okay.
How many of you think the more time,
wait,
sorry.
Did I say face to face men to say faith.
How many think face to face?
The more time spent in face to face interaction at the workplace is associated
with happier mood at the end of the day.
Okay.
And how many of you think the more time spent on Facebook is associated with a
happier mood?
At the end of the day,
we have one person and one person.
You are correct.
It is Facebook.
The more time people spend on Facebook.
Now why would that be the case?
Right?
It's counterintuitive.
Well,
we dug into the data and we found that when people spent more time on Facebook,
they were also more engaged in their work for that day.
And now it makes sense because if you're really working,
you're really focused and engaged in your work.
Uh,
the last thing you want to have as a face to face interaction,
because when you have a face to face interaction,
you're a prisoner of that interaction,
right?
You have the greeting ritual and the attraction and the partying ritual,
and you can't just break away very quickly.
But with Facebook you can do what we call grazing behavior.
You can move in and out pretty quickly,
right under your control.
And so that's why we think when people were engaged in their work,
Facebook offers them away to,
to do grazing behavior to take breaks under their control.
So what about if we block distractions?
What happens?
Is it a good strategy to block distractions?
Everybody complains about distractions from digital media and there's not just a
plethora of commercial apps that are developed to enable people to block
distractions.
Two basic approaches.
One is you just simply cut off,
uh,
sites that people feel would be distracting.
And the other approach is that you show people the amount of time they spend on
different sites to increase their awareness,
right?
With the idea that if people become aware how much time they spend on social
media,
they might take action to change.
So we did a field study,
32 information workers.
Uh,
we looked around for a commercial software to use.
We found freedom software,
which seems like a pretty good choice.
Um,
we measured people five days baseline the way they work normally.
And then five days they worked.
They were told to work as they normally would,
but they use this freedom blocking software to block distractions.
We let people choose what distractions they wanted to,
um,
to block.
It comes with a default list of distractions and then people could personalize
it according to what they felt was most distracting for them.
We used a scale that's called cognitive absorption,
which has the following dimensions.
These are all related to the eye,
the idea of focusing.
And we found that when distractions were cut off,
people's focused immersion in their task increased significantly.
Temporal dissociation,
discrete,
decreased temporal dissociation is,
is being unaware of time.
People became more aware of time when,
uh,
distractions were blocked.
There was no difference in people's sense of control,
which totally surprised us.
We thought there wouldn't be and peoples' enjoyment decreased while we took away
people's social media and there was no difference in curiosity.
Another dimension,
a focus increased.
Uh,
we interviewed everyone.
Two main reasons.
We removed what's called attention residue.
That's the idea of let's say you go on Facebook,
you become involved in the content and that content stays with you.
And when you switch back to your task,
he was still thinking about Facebook.
We took that residue away,
we stopped chains of distraction.
People report just rabbit holing,
they go onto the internet and then they just,
before they know it,
they're just kind of lost.
Uh,
but when we looked at the interviews,
we found there are actually two very distinct groups of people,
those who reported being high in self control of their work and those who
reported being low.
And indeed when we did some more analyses,
we found people who had high self control.
We're significantly more conscientious.
It's a personality trait and they were significantly less impulsive.
Okay.
Now we went back and we looked at the data again in terms of these two different
groups and we found something really interesting that the low self control
group,
they're distractions were blocked.
There really was no difference in their workload.
The amount of um,
mental expenditure that they,
um,
that they had.
Yes.
Glx is the NASA TLX scale.
It's measure of workload.
So it's a very common,
very well validated,
uh,
scale that's used for workload.
However,
we found something interesting with the high self control group,
people who are very conscientious people,
that means they're very diligent in their work.
Uh,
people who feel that they're in control of their work.
When distractions were cut off,
guess what?
Their workload increased significantly.
So we found this,
this interesting interaction.
Why is that the case?
Um,
well the reason is because people,
these are diligent people work hard and they did not take breaks.
Whereas the people who had low self control,
they wa,
you know,
they took physical breaks,
they went to the Coffee Room Wart,
they interacted with people more.
Um,
but people who were very,
uh,
you know,
high in self control continued to work straight through without breaks.
So of course their workload increased and their stress increased significantly.
One person missed her shuttle at the end of the day,
never happened before it because she was so immersed in work and,
and didn't even take any breaks.
So we see there's individual differences in,
in the use of this kind of software to block distractions.
People with low self regulation,
right?
We see they're more likely to take physical breaks.
We see less cognitive switching.
So we,
they did focus significantly longer.
And so we hypothesized that the purpose of this kind of software,
it's to offload this regulation ability to the software.
People don't have that ability.
It's not,
you know,
innate for them.
So they offloaded onto the software people who already have high self
regulation,
well,
when they use those kind of software to block distractions,
they work longer,
fewer physical breaks,
and as a result,
higher workload.
And so our hypotheses is that using this kind of software actually interferes
with people's ability to self regulate,
right?
They do pretty well on their own.
And so this whole idea of these,
you know,
this,
this huge business in a distraction blocking software that one size fits all,
it's not true.
So there's a lot of opportunities to improve work experience based on this work.
For example,
we can,
um,
think about balancing wrote and focused work throughout the day,
right?
We don't want to overload people.
We want to think about balancing people's moods.
Uh,
we can think about scheduling work based on attention patterns.
And we can also think it's an opportunity for interventions that can nudge
people to increase focus,
uh,
reduce stress and improve their mood.
And deciding of nudging is something I've been thinking about quite a bit and
thinking about blocking distractions,
but only for those with low control.
Um,
okay.
Now I'm going to put on my psychologist hat to close here.
Okay.
So,
so bear with me.
Um,
throughout the history of psychology,
there has always been this idea that people take actions in order to achieve a
kind of balanced,
emotional and psychological state.
It's,
it's this common thread through eons of research.
Hippocrates talked about this idea of harmonious,
balanced with health and gestalt theorists,
if you're familiar with them,
talked about this,
the law of pragmatics,
a Canon talked about homeostasis.
My favorite psychologists of all is Kurt Lewin,
who talked about this idea of field theory,
who said that everything we do in life,
every action we take is designed to reduce tension because tension is
uncomfortable.
And,
uh,
you're probably familiar with cognitive dissonance theory,
which also is this idea of how people can restore,
reduce this kind of imbalance between their attitudes and their behaviors.
And so,
uh,
I would like to leave you with this idea that maybe people adjust their use of
digital media in order to try to achieve an internal balance.
So because information workers spend a good part most of their day working with
digital media,
maybe people use it in such a way that they're,
they're trying to create this internal balance.
So the way they take breaks or don't take breaks or the kinds of,
uh,
applications they choose to work on.
Want to quickly talk about,
uh,
another project that I've just been starting working on.
This is the largest sensing project yet that we have ever done and to my
knowledge that anyone has ever done in the workplace.
And the idea here is to predict,
uh,
the workplace experience.
So people's health and wellbeing using unobtrusive sensors,
that's really key.
We can't introduce any of sensors that would disrupt people's,
uh,
work experience.
Uh,
our goal is to track 750 workers over one year.
we have to date about 708 in the study and we wanted to be for a whole year
because then we can track life events.
We can look at what is the effect of a significant life events like births and
deaths and job changes and marriages and divorces.
And uh,
we can look at seasons and how that affects and how all of this can be fed into
the sensor data to help understand how it affects people's work.
Lots.
And we will use a robust sensing system,
uh,
comprised of wearable devices,
beacons,
phone agent,
and we will use social media but not look at content.
We will just look at metadata and you can learn more here.
Uh,
this work could not have been done without the collaboration of a number of
really great colleagues who are listed here.
And I'd like to thank,
uh,
funders and our participants.
Thank you.
So if anyone has any questions,
we had the question box
restrooms.
What's the difference between like being bored and stress between what?
Boredom and stress,
low stress.
How do you distinguish low stress from boredom?
Yeah.
Oh boy.
Okay.
So,
um,
there is actually,
they are actually related but you can have low stress and be happy.
So there is the circumplex model of nude where,
um,
if you have,
you can have low energy and negative aspect and that's different from having
negative effect and,
and um,
high energy,
that quadrant negative aspect,
high energy would be defined as stress and the quadrant of negative affect and
low energy would be,
uh,
related to boredom.
Thanks.
Yeah.
So most of your explanations are in terms of mood being effected by what work
you do,
to what extent you think your data might be,
uh,
a case of what work you choose to do depending on your mood.
Oh,
fascinating.
Um,
we cannot,
we actually can't assign clause alad.
Right.
And I did not mean to imply causality here is,
it's all correlation.
Just like with these huge medical studies,
you know,
like smoking and lung cancer,
we can imply causality.
Um,
so we can't disentangle that.
Right.
And,
um,
and it wouldn't be,
it would be an interesting study,
but that would have to be more of an experimental nature to be able to induce
different kinds of moods and then to see what kind of work people choose.
But it's,
it's hard when you're just tracking people in these kinds of observational
studies to try to infer causality.
But it's a,
it's a good question.
Stick work.
So,
um,
I print this is information workers,
so it's presumably an open office,
sort of a set up,
a mixed,
it's mixed.
Yeah.
Actually most of them were not in open office settings.
Okay.
Do you think that has any bearing on like um,
attention and things like that?
Yes.
Uh,
so it certainly has a bearing on interruptions.
And so in other work we found that in an open office setting,
people were more likely to be interrupted for work that was peripheral to what
they were doing.
Right.
So your colleagues help me debug this or what's your opinion on this?
And it's not worked for which they are accountable.
It's not tasks that they're assigned to do.
This happens more in open office settings.
Is that a good thing or a bad thing?
Well,
you know,
if you ask individuals,
they might say,
wow,
it's not a good thing.
If you ask management,
they might say,
yeah,
that's a good thing.
We're,
we're sharing expertise.
What about a sense of agency and like,
so like you're saying,
so it seems like it's a competition of wills,
right?
Like who's going to win out as management gonna win?
Or do you think,
do you think an open office deprives workers have a sense of agency and Lawrence
in determining when there'll be distracted thinking of it?
Yeah,
that's,
that's really interesting.
I'm not sure I wouldn't use the word agency.
Um,
I would,
I would guess that people who have a strong sense of agency,
high self regulation should be able to somehow create barriers.
But this would be at a cost of perhaps being a solo shop and not being good
colleagues.
So there was,
there was this social trade off as well,
right?
That it's not just agency,
it's the idea.
You want to be a good organizational citizen,
right.
You and you want to,
um,
expense social capital's so that you get social benefits in return someday,
someday when you have a problem and you want to be able to tap into someone
else's expertise.
So I think there was a lot of interesting things at play.
A agency is perhaps one thing,
but there's all kinds of social dynamics as well.
That's a little
sure.
Um,
so I was brought up about causation,
but with the long handle data that you're planning,
you will know something about mood before people start work and then can you
then look at the work they choose to do?
Yeah,
absolutely.
So we're with this,
we can log a time series when we have this kind of longitudinal data.
I mean we've,
we've looked at people over weeks,
right?
And to some extent we tend see,
uh,
this kind of causality based on time,
but I would be a lot more confident to look at it over a much longer period of
time.
I mean,
for example,
we know that weather affects mood,
it's causality because it's not the other way around.
Right?
So,
so,
um,
we,
we can look at factors like that and,
you know,
how does the stock market or,
uh,
the factors that are really external to the workplace and how that's affecting
people.
And there's also this kind of cyclical behavior.
For example,
um,
I have looked at sleep debt.
Sleep debt is the accumulation of loss of sleep over time.
And you can,
it's kind of a cyclical pattern because if you don't get a lot of sleep,
we find that people spend more time on lightweight activities like social media,
Facebook,
because it's easy,
right?
And,
and then you sleep less.
Oh,
maybe it's because you didn't get your work done and your,
uh,
you know,
you need to,
to work longer hours.
So there can be these kinds of cyclical effects.
Okay.